and welcome to our friends and members
of our SumTV family. You are watching
I'd like to know our Bible question and
answer program here on SumTV. You send
in the Bible-based questions, we will
give you from the word of God a
Bible-based answer to those self-same
questions. So, thank you for joining us.
If you want to be part of this program,
and we pray that you do, send your
questions to tvsumtv.org.
That is tv.sum
as in marytv.org.
And we will answer them just as quickly
as we can. I am Pastor CA Murray. To my
right, Pastor Steven Bore. To my left,
Pastor David Salazar. Gentlemen, always
good to share the desk with you and
answer questions from the word of God.
>> Amen.
>> It's always a blessing. Uh, Pastor
Salazar, would you ask God's blessing on
us as we prepare to uh, begin today's
program?
>> Certainly. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we are coming before
you at this hour to ask that you will
grant us the understanding of your word.
Give us the Holy Spirit to be able to
discern and to give answers that are
according to your will and may clarify
and bring uh deeper understanding of
your scriptures to those who are sending
the questions, those who are watching
and are listening to the program. We
want to glorify your name. May you be
lifted up and we may give honor to you
through the study of your word. We pray
this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our [snorts] first
question to us comes to us from South
Africa. We've gotten a number of
questions from the African continent and
from around the world which is uh
something that is music to our ears uh
because it knows that we lets us know
that our footprint is is covering the
earth's surface and we are thankful for
that. Stephen writes to us from South
Africa. I greet you as brothers in
Christ and humbly seek your counsel on a
matter that has arisen within our
Adventist congregation. We understand
that the current system of timekeeping,
including the names and structure of the
days of the week, has been altered from
the original design established by God
at creation. As scripture records, and
there was evening, and there was
morning, the first day, and so forth.
While we faithfully observe the Sabbath
from sundown on Friday to sundown on
Saturday, a question has emerged. How
should we as Christians reconcile living
the rest of the week within [snorts] the
framework of the Gregorian calendar, a
system that does not reflect God's
original calendar.
We are not questioning the importance of
order and structure in society, but
rather seeking spiritual clarity on how
to remain faithful uh in our daily walk
while navigating a timekeeping system
that differs from the biblical model.
your wisdom and biblical insight would
be greatly appreciated.
Um, back in the the Jewish
the days of Israel and and to some
extent up until today, the calendar was
based on days with reference to the
Sabbath. Uh, he proti
Periskevi, you know, one unto the
Sabbath, two unto the Sabbath, three
unto the Sabbath, four unto the Sabbath,
five under the Sabbath, eve of the
Sabbath, Sabbath. Those names are no
longer in use. But that which is
constant is the fact that there were
seven days at creation, there are seven
days now. So the number has not been
altered, although the days have been
altered. And the names of the days
>> and the names name I'm sorry m the names
of the days have have been changed but
the number has not been changed. There
were seven then there are seven now. We
know we keep the seventh day regardless
of name. Call it what you want. Uh
different languages in Spanish it is
called
>> savvado.
>> Savado English called Sabbath. Um many
names all tending to sound a little bit
alike by the way but always seven. So we
don't keep the day by name. We keep the
day by number and that has not changed.
>> Right.
>> Exactly. And and it's interesting to
know that uh yes, the original Hebrew
calendar that the Lord gave the Jewish
individuals was a way to keep time and
to give dates for holidays, for feasts,
and for the harvest and the agriculture
planning that they had to do. However,
the 7-day cycle from creation has been
uninterrupted, has been kept. And now,
uh we have to understand that there were
other
countries, other nations who kept other
types of calendars, but uh ultimately
wherever the Hebrews were, they were m
they were sure to keep that seven-day
cycle alive. And to a certain degree the
world as a whole adopted that idea of
seven days. And give you an example in
the year 45 BC
uh Julius Caesar implemented the Julian
calendar
>> to the whole Roman Empire. the whole
empire was going to be under that type
of timekeeping which was in that time
the most accurate to their understanding
and they didn't want to use the Hebrew
one because they added an extra month
every sea years. So it seemed to be the
one that was more accurate. Now that
Julian calendar again was based on seven
days. So the cycle of the seven days the
s same week was kept. Now was it kept in
the sense of s you know sunset to
sunset? Probably not. Um and yet that
does not mean that this calendar was not
honored or uh used by the disciples by
the Jewish individuals around the world.
So uh for example we go to the first uh
to the book of um you know first Peter
chapter 2 verse 13 it says something
very clearly there that we need to keep
in mind. It says, "Therefore submit
yourselves to every ordinance of men for
the Lord's sake, whether to the kings as
supreme, whether to the king as supreme,
or to governors, as to those who are
sent by him for the punishment of
evildoers, and for the praise of those
who do good. For this is the will of
God, that by doing good, you may put to
silence the ignorance of foolish men."
So in a sense the apostle Peter is
saying the ordinances and things of the
powers that be of the civil powers do
that if they have a calendar where you
have to say I'm going to work Monday
through Friday even though those are
those are names of the moon gods
whatever it it's not going to affect you
by doing that as long as you keep the
seven day Sabbath as the Lord commanded
to be and by the grace of God he has
allowed that the cycle of the seven days
as we mentioned has not been destroyed
or been altered. So you can keep the
seven-day Sabbath knowing full well that
is the seven-day Sabbath of creation.
And whether or not you have to uh you
choose to keep the other days of the
week from midnight to midnight. Well,
guess what? When you come to Friday,
that Friday evening is Sabbath. You
start the Sabbath. And so you interrupt
that ordinance of men for what the Lord
has established. But after that, keeping
time, keeping the dates, keeping the the
you know the other aspects of the
calendar that we use today is not in any
way uh going against the Lord or or is
going to take you away in a path of
unrighteousness because again that's
just not connected to the actual
experience of keeping the seven Sabbath.
is just a way to keep time, keep track
of the dates and so forth of our
everyday life.
>> The the Gregorian calendar came in the
the closing decades of the 16th century,
>> correct?
>> Late 1500s.
>> Um and they had enough control of their
understanding of astrology to know that
they had missed some days. So when they
changed them, they didn't change the the
cycle or the number of days. Matthew and
Mark both record Christ saying, "Render
unto God the things that are God. run to
Caesar the things that are things that
are Caesar.
When you get your paycheck,
there's a certain part of that paycheck
that God claims as his.
The rest of your paycheck, there is some
discretion as to how you use it. As a
Christian, you determine how that is
going to be spent. Now, your your
guidelines come from God, but uh it's
yours to spend as you wish. When you
give out when you give God his
>> well the only day that of the week that
God has claimed as his is Sabbath.
>> You have some discretion as to how you
spend your time during the rest of the
week. Now you're you're you're told not
to waste it. You've got to work if you
want to eat. There are certain
guidelines, but within those guidelines,
you have discretion to to do what you
need to do. Some of that discretion is
going to be uh claimed [snorts] by the
state. The government says you have to
do certain things. You've got to do
those things. You have discretion to do
that without feeling you are going
against the principles of God because he
claims this time the rest of those that
time you have some discretion as to how
you do it. So I don't believe that you
need to superimpose
Bible time sundown to sun sundown to
sundown on top of your other week. you
have discretion to to do what you need
to do during that time.
>> You know, the devil is kind of sly.
>> Uh many calendars in Europe and in Latin
America begin the week with Monday.
>> True.
>> And there's an there's an agenda to that
because the purpose of beginning with
Monday is to make Sunday the seventh day
of the week.
>> It's the devil's sly way of saying that
the seventh day is Sunday. Uh but that
doesn't work because the Bible says that
the seventh day is the Sabbath.
[laughter]
>> Exactly.
>> So So it's a it's a human gimmick to try
and convince people that Sunday I is
really the seventh day of the week when
really it's the first day of the week.
>> And it's interesting pastor that you
know the
you know the the the religious entities
of this world that keep Sunday as a day
of worship. uh early on they all
understood that the seventh day Sabbath
is Saturday. It's is a seven-day
Sabbath. So they are well aware that
even those gimmicks are not biblically
correct. And so today we have as you
will said pastor CA you know we have the
G gregorian calendar who was implemented
in I think 1548 that
>> 1582
>> 1582 thank you
>> 82 correct by Pope Gregory the 8th
>> and it was to correct this discrepancy
of several days that had been
accumulated over the past 1500 years
that this Julius Julian calendar was had
kept because they will add uh roughly 11
minutes to each day uh to each year
rather. But in that change in that
change from the Julian to the Gregor
Gregorian calendar those days that were
needed to be adjusted never impacted the
cycle of the week. Again the seven-day
cycle has remained the same. So uh
>> and the sequence of days not only the
7day cycle correct
>> but also uh
>> the sequence
>> it wasn't changed the calendar didn't
change from Sunday to Wednesday or
something like that you know basically
it just eliminated from October 4 to
October 15
>> correct so they eliminated the day the
days the dates but not the days
themselves right so like you said
they're very well it was a well adjusted
connect correction
>> and again this allows us to understand
that today there are situations where
you're going to have your you know
secular powers sort of demand you to
keep the work day into seven Sabbath
hours and that's when you have to know
where your allegiance ends
>> when the the the you know when the
government your civil power steps over
the line of God then you have to you
know be faithful to the Lord but when
it's not in in contrary to the law of
God when it's not going to affect you
you're honoring the Lord keeping the day
you know like I said calling it Monday
Sunday whatever it's not really going to
make any difference again is not what is
going to determine whether you're fil to
the Lord the calendar itself is not
going to affect you that it's really
just how you honor the Lord by keeping
the Sabbath day holy as he asked us to
do
>> if I can just read a statement from
Ellen White uh I think is it's very
important important that she realized
that the weekly cycle has never been
broken.
>> Uh this statement is in Signs of the
Times, March 20, 1879.
>> Yeah.
>> The first week in which God performed
the work of creation in six days and
rested on the seventh was just like
every other week. The great God in his
days of creation, the day of rest,
measured off the first cycle as a sample
for successive weeks till the close of
time.
>> Amen.
>> The weekly cycle of seven literal days,
six for labor, and the seventh for rest,
which has been preserved and brought
down through Bible history, originated
in the facts of the first seven days. So
she very clearly says that uh the weekly
cycle of seven literal days, six for
labor and se seventh for the rest which
has been preserved and brought down
through Bible history there's not been
any change and you know it's interesting
I had once a conversation with uh with
somebody who was a Sunday sun Sunday
keeper and um uh he said uh you know how
do you know that the Sabbath that you
keep is the same Sabbath that existed in
That is days of Christ.
>> And uh you know I might have changed. So
I asked him I said uh what day of the
week do you uh keep? He says well I keep
Sunday. I said why do you keep Sunday?
He said well I keep Sunday because
that's the day read Jesus resurrected.
>> So you're saying that the the Sunday we
keep today is the same Sunday of the
resurrection. He says of course. I said
well if Sunday is the same Sunday the
Sabbath is the same Sabbath. So then he
came at me in a different direction. And
he said, "How do you know that the
Sabbath today is the same Sabbath of
creation?"
And I said, "Because because Jesus
created the Sabbath and he would we
wouldn't be keeping the wrong day. He
would never have lo permitted it to be
lost."
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. Praise the Lord. Well
said. Well said. Um [clears throat]
it's never been changed. Even though
certain religious bodies have have
claimed to transfer the sacredness of
the day, you still got seven days,
>> right?
>> And the only person who could ever make
that change if the change was indeed to
be made would be God himself.
>> Correct.
>> So, uh I think we're on safe ground,
pastor.
>> Absolutely. And you know, in heaven, we
will have a different type of uh
calendar, the perfect one. Um but yet we
will keep sevenday Sabbath once again.
You know, the Sabbath we will be
honoring. And so God will continue to
honor the same cycle week, the same days
of the week um you know in the new
earth. Uh but while we are here, let's
render to Caesar what's Caesars and to
God what's God's.
>> And praise the Lord that there will be
no international date line. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> No jet lag. Of course, if we're going to
travel to heaven in seven days to the
depths of Orion,
you know, I'm not so sure that uh that
time is going to be that significant in
the kingdom come.
>> Yeah, indeed.
>> There will be seven days.
>> Yes.
>> But it won't take us u it won't take us
hours and hours to get from here to
South Africa.
>> 22 hours in the air when you go through
London. [laughter]
>> We'll probably be flying at much faster
speeds.
>> Yes. Another thing we won't have to deal
with is a change of one hour in the
spring and in the fall.
>> Amen. Amen. [laughter]
>> A lot of good things.
>> Amen.
>> Alrighty. Thank you so very much. Now,
this question that comes to us, there's
no name and and no um area where it's
coming from, but the qu the person wants
to know and their inquiry is what does
the Adventist church say about white
Christian nationalism and what is their
official stance? Are they for or against
it? [snorts] The idea of Christian
nationalism and white Christian
nationalism is something that is
is fairly new to our popular culture, to
our our parliament, although the maybe
the ideas have been around for a while.
Um, I wish I had a little more of an
idea of what he means by the term
because the term, depending on whose
mouth it's coming from, does have
slightly different iterations.
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
a couple of things occur to me very
quickly.
>> One, God is no respector of persons. So
when you lead with white or black or any
any other color or racial designation,
you are already in trouble as far as
heaven sees what you're you're talking
about. Mhm.
>> Um, race is an artificial construct
which is a demonic insertion into the
human family.
>> Um, there's a great book that I'm
finishing reading called Why Are We So
Polarized? by Ezra Klein, a Jewish guy.
And [snorts] he says it is natural for
human beings to find differences where
really none exist
>> because it feeds into our desire for
superiority. [snorts]
>> So once we
divest ourselves of the desire to to be
superior then a lot of these racial
problems uh solve themselves. So when
you lead with the word right, my antenna
go up, white rather, my antenna go up
because anything that's based on black
or white or rich or poor or these
artificial differences uh is problematic
when you put it into practice. My main
concern is not white Christian
nationalism but Christian nationalism
[laughter]
because Christian nationalism it
actually has its roots long before this.
>> You know in in the 1970s and 80s Pat
Robertson and uh Jerry Fwell
>> and you know they they were Christian
nationalists. Mhm.
>> They basically believe that this nation
should be run as a theocracy
>> and that the government should be
involved in enforcing religion.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh that's where I find uh the
serious uh flaws in this idea of
Christian nationalism. Uh the founders
of the nation if they resurrected now
and saw what people were proposing, they
would die of a heart attack.
>> I'm speaking figuratively, of course.
Um, so, uh, there's no room that I don't
think that the Seventh Day Adventist
Church has any position that we should,
uh, support Christian nationalism
because we've had a strong stance
throughout our entire history of the
separation of church and state
>> and not have the church uh, the state do
the work of the church. And Christian
nationalism is pretty well founded on
the idea that the church should use the
state to enforce morality and to enforce
religion. Yes,
>> there is a you know the question that
this individual is asking about what is
the official church stand in back in
January 18, 2021 the uh general
conference public affairs and religious
liberty department wrote an article
and regards this particular question
where does the Adventist churches stand
regarding Christian nationalism as you
will said pastor bore pastor cier you
know this movement of Christian
nationalism is the idea a of bringing
together church and state to ending that
separation and combining them together.
>> Now uh there are many things in this
article that you know it's too long to
read the whole thing and I recommend you
to to look for it is is available uh at
the in the internet general conference
again public affairs and religious
liberty department but I want to
basically go to the part where it says
where do adventists seven adventists
stand in regards to this. It says, "The
Seventh Day Adventist Church is
absolutely clear on how it views
Christian nationalism. This ideology is
anti-ethical to our theology and beliefs
and alien to our deeply held values. A a
helpful review of the church's unique
understanding of church state relations
can be found in a document adopted by
the council of interurch interfaith
faith relations of the general
conference in March 2002 which is posted
on the advent website. It reminds us of
the clear biblical framework and
prophetic council that undergurts how
the adventist church and its members
should relate to the civic realm. A key
idea found here is a warning against
partisanship. This princ the principle
is both clear and simple. The church,
its various institutions and its
representatives will never align with
any political party or political
ideology.
>> So another principle is that as as a
denomination, we will not seek political
preference and we do not use our
influence with political and civil
leaders to either advance our faith or
inhibit the faith of others. In fact,
around the world within many different
political contexts, we forcefully
advocate against the alignment of any
religious group, Christian or otherwise,
with political authority. So this is in
a nutshell what the Adventist church
stands for and why we are as a church
completely against this idea of
Christian nationalism which is again the
idea of bringing together church and
state and creating a Christian nation
that regulates worship regulates
Christianity and that is not correct
that's not biblical is against our ethic
is are against our beliefs and our core
understanding of scripture. The sad
thing is that there are many members in
the Adventist church that have embraced
Christian nationalism. And and the
reason why I think is because society
has gone against scripture uh in many
areas like for example transgenderism,
gay marriage, uh abortion, you know, uh
because uh because those things are
promoted in society.
>> The idea is let's take control of the
government
>> to forbid those things so that we have
once again a moral nation. Mhm.
>> But it doesn't work that way. The change
does not come through legislation. The
change comes through the work of the
Holy Spirit in the human heart.
>> Precisely. That's our our pulpit is the
heart. U not the judges of Gavl. Um a
book you want to maybe take a look at is
Deline Sunday by Warren Josh, which
talks about the the imposition of of of
the church in state affairs and the
problems that arise from that. And of
course, we've got at Jones uh speaking
before the the Congress in the late
1800s. Again, a lot to talk about. U our
time has gotten away from us. Hopefully,
this program has been a blessing to you.
It's been a blessing to us to study.
We'll see you again soon. Bye-bye and
God bless.